SAD KICKOFF RALLY IS ANY
INDICATION, VOTERS ARE NOT
EXCITED.
I DON'T SEE EXCITEMENT FOR ANY
OF THESE CANDIDATES.
JOINING IS NOW, SENATOR TED CRUZ
FROM THE GREAT STATE OF TEXAS.
SENATOR, HOW ARE YOU?
>> BE WITH YOU.
>> Sean: I WATCH AND I WATCH
CLOSELY AND I PLAY VERY CLOSE
ATTENTION, IT'S NOT EVERY
SECOND, MINUTE, HOUR OF EVERY
DAY HATING DONALD TRUMP, THEN IS
THE NEW GREENDALE, THEN IT'S
SOCIALISM AT A LEVEL WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE WITH A
PROTECTABLE RESULT, CORRECT?
>> THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT --
>> Sean: TAKE A SIP OF WATER.
IT HAPPENS, DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT, SENATOR.
IT'S OKAY.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS SEEM TO HAVE A
FEW AGENDA ITEMS, EATING DRUM,
NEW GREENDALE.
>> THE DEBATE LAST NIGHT, THE
CLOWN CAR HAS BROKEN.
THERE IS NO BREAK AND IT ONLY
STEERS.
IT WAS SCARY LAST NIGHT.
IT WAS SCARY TO SEE THE
DEMOCRATS FALLING ALL OVER EACH
OTHER TO GET FURTHER AND FURTHER
AND FURTHER LEFT.
THE DEMOCRATS, YOU JUST WENT
THROUGH THEIR MONOLOG
POWERFULLY.
YOU SAW THEM EMBRACE LATE-TERM
ABORTIONS, HE SAW THEM EMBRACE
70% TAX RATE, SOCIALISM, THEY
WANT TO TAKE AWAY EVERYONE'S
HEALTH INSURANCE.
AND YOU SAW THEM EMBRACE OPEN
BORDERS.
ONE OF THE MOST DISTURBING
EXCHANGES WAS WHEN THE SOME OF
THOSE CANDIDATES BEGAN SAYING
THEY WANTED TO ELIMINATE THE
PROVISION AND LAW THAT MAKES IT
ILLEGAL TO CROSS THE BORDER.
MAKES IT A CRIME TO CROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY.
AS YOU KNOW, LAST MONTH, WE
APPREHENDED 144,000 PEOPLE IN
THE MONTH OF MAY CROSSING
ILLEGALLY.
THE DEMOCRATIC SOLUTION IS LET'S
NOT MAKE IT A CRIME.
THERE YOU GO, THE PROBLEM GOES
AWAY.
THAT IS OPEN BORDERS, IT IS A
RESPONSIBLE, AND IT IS SADLY
WHERE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS
TODAY.
>> Sean: HOW DID WE GO FROM
SUPPORTING OBAMA'S POSITION TO
ITS IMMORAL, THE GUY YOU KNEW,
ROBERT FRANCIS, BOZO, BETO,
WHATEVER IT IS, HE IS SAYING
TEAR DOWN THE WALLS, BUT 90% OF
AMERICA'S HEROIN COMES ACROSS
THE BORDER, WE ARE LOSING 300
PEOPLE A WEEK IN THE OPIOID
CRISIS, THEN SENTINEL, ADD THAT
TO THE
MIX.
I'VE INTERVIEWED THESE BORDER
AGENTS WHO HAVE SPENT OVER A
DECADE TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN,
YOUNG GIRLS BEING TRAFFIC FOR
PROSTITUTION.
>> WE HAVE BOTH BEEN BACK TO THE
BORDER TO REALLY TRY TO
HIGHLIGHT THE CRISIS WE
ARE HAVING THERE.
WE SAW SOME POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
TODAY CONGRESS FINALLY PASSED
WHAT THE PRESIDENT ASKED FOR,
THAT INCLUDES OVER A BILLION
DOLLARS FOR BORDER CONTROL, A
TRILLION DOLLARS FOR I.C.E.
THAT IS GOOD BUT HERE IS THE BAD
NEWS, THE DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS
REFUSED TO CLOSE THE LOOPHOLES
CAUSING THIS CRISIS.
THEY REFUSED TO DO ANYTHING TO
FIX THE CRISIS AND I WILL TELL
YOU ONE OF THE MOST DISTURBING
REPORTS I AM GETTING, I AM
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FO
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FM
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FL
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FW
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FE
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FF
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FR
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FE
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FT
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FO
GETTING MORE AND MORE REPORTS FF
CARTELS AND TRAFFICKERS RENTING
CHILDREN.
BECAUSE IDIOTIC POLICY THAT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE PUT IN PLACE IS
THAT IF SOMEONE SHOWS UP WITH A
CHILD, THAT THEY ARE ALLOWED TO
STAY AND GO FREE, AND AS A
RESULT, YOU ARE SEEING LITTLE
CHILDREN WHO ARE SUDDENLY
FINDING MORE AND MORE INSTANCES
OF CHILDREN WITH ADULTS WHO ARE
NOW THEIR FAMILY, THAT ARE
STRANGERS TO THEM, BUT THE CHILD
IS ESSENTIALLY THERE GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD.
THAT IS CRUEL TO INCENTIVIZE
KIDS BEING ABUSED LIKE THAT AND
THE DEMOCRATS ON THAT STAGE, THE
DEMOCRATS ON THE STAGE RIGHT
NOW, NOT A SINGLE ONE OF THEM IS
WILLING TO DO ANYTHING TO FIX I
IT.
>> Sean: OPEN BORDERS AND
AMNESTY IS A BIG PART OF THEIR
AGENDA, I DON'T EVEN THINK THERE
ARE ANY RESTRICTIONS ON
ABORTIONS.
THEY MAKE IT INTO WHAT HAPPENED
IN VIRGINIA AND ALL THESE OTHER
STATES WHERE WE TALK ABOUT
DURING THE FOURTH -- IT'S NOT
ABORTION, IT'S INFANTICIDE.
POST BIRTH INFANTICIDE.
THEN WE'VE GOT A 70% TOP
MARGINAL TAX RATE FOR
INDIVIDUALS.
90% FOR CORPORATIONS.
HOW MANY PEOPLE'S TAXES IN TERMS
OF GETTING POPULATION, IT WASN'T
A CLOSE TO 400,000 IN THE LAST
YEAR OR TWO?
>> WE GET OVER 1,000 PEOPLE A
DAY MOVE INTO THE STATE OF
TEXAS.
WHY QUESTION RIGHT BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE JOBS ARE.
THEY ARE FLEEING STATES LIKE
CALIFORNIA AND NEW YORK.
>> Sean: WAIT A MINUTE,
MIKE HUCKABEE SAT ON THE SHOW
THE OTHER DAY, IF YOU ARE TAKING
A U-HAUL FROM CALIFORNIA TO
TEXAS IT'S ABOUT $1600.
I HAVE NOT HEARD THIS.
BUT IF YOU ARE RETURNING, YOU'RE
BASICALLY DOING U-HAUL A FAVOR,
IT'S $400 BUT IT IS PROBABLY
NEGOTIABLE.
THEY MIGHT GIVE IT TO YOU FOR
$100.
A SPIGOT THAT IS EXACTLY RIGHT,
FOR A LONG TIME
, THE PRICE DIFFERENTIAL, GOING
TO CALIFORNIA VERSUS GOING TO
TEXAS IS ABOUT 300% PRICE
DIFFERENTIAL
IN U-HAUL, THAT IS BEEN TRUE FOR
YEARS BECAUSE EVERYONE IS
FLEEING THE SINKING SHIP, AS YOU
HAVE THE CRAZY LEFT JACKING UP
TAXES, JACKING UP REGULATIONS.
AND WELCOMING PEOPLE COMING
ILLEGALLY.
AND THE JOB PRODUCERS, THE SMALL
BUSINESS OWNERS ARE FLEEING THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, AND IN
TEXAS -- I'LL TELL YOU SOMETHING
INTERESTING, THE STORY CAME AT A
COUPLE MONTHS AGO.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE NUMBER ONE
CITY IN THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA FOR MILLENNIALS MOVING
INTO HIS?
MY HOMETOWN OF HOUSTON.
THEY ARE MOVING TO THE MOST
DIVERSITY IN AMERICA, WHY?
BECAUSE OF THE JOBS.
THERE ARE JOBS IN THE WAGES ARE
GOING UP AND YOU HAVE
OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE THE
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T PUT THEIR
BOOT ON THE BACK OF THE NECKS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES.
>> Sean: IT'S INTERESTING,
BILL MAHER, I DON'T LIKE HIM BUT
HE SOMETIMES MAKES SOME VERY
HONEST STATEMENTS.
HE SAID NOT A GOOD START BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T ANSWER THE FIRST
QUESTION.
70% OF AMERICANS -- WE NOW HAVE
THE BEST EMPLOYMENT SITUATION IN
AMERICA SINCE 1969.
PRINCIPAL, BY THE WAY, THAT YOU
HAVE SUPPORTED YOUR ENTIRE
CAREER, CUTTING TAXES, WE
ARE NOW ENERGY DEPENDENT FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN 75 YEARS.
AT THE NEW GREENDALE SAYS NO
OIL, NO GAS IN TEN YEARS.
BY THE WAY, MANY OF THEM ARE
BUYING INTO THIS INSANITY, THE
NEW GREENDALE.
WHAT WAS THAT DUE TO ESTATE
LIGHT TEXAS, WHAT WITH THAT DUE
TO THE ECONOMY IN GENERAL IF YOU
HAD A 70% AND 90% TAX RATE?
>> IT WOULD DESTROY OPPORTUNITY
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT WAY FROM BELMAR, I
RETWEETED TODAY BILL MAHER
BECAUSE HIS TWEET WAS EXACTLY
RIGHT, HE SAID THE FIRST
QUESTION IN THE DEBATE --
>> Sean: TED CRUZ RETREATING
BELMAR, I LIKE THAT.
SPEAK UP BUT HE RIGHTLY POINTED
OUT, HE SAID 70% OF AMERICANS
SAY THE ECONOMY IS DOING WELL.
WHY DO YOU GUYS THINK WE SHOULD
CHANGE IT?
AND NOT ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS HAD
AN ANSWER.
WE'VE GOT -- YOU AND YOUR
VIEWERS KNOW THIS, WE HAVE GOT
THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT AND 50
YEARS, LOWEST AFRICAN-AMERICAN
UNEMPLOYMENT EVER RECORDED,
LOWEST HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT
EVER RECORDED.
WHAT THEY ARE PROPOSING, THE
GREEN NEW DEAL WOULD COST WILL
COST $93 MILLION.
IT'S HARD TO UNDERSTAND
1 MILLION, A TRILLION, A
BILLION, BUT LET ME PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE.
$93 TRILLION IS MORE MONEY THAN
THE ENTERAL GOVERNMENT HAS SPENT
IN THE ENTIRE HISTORY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA GOING
BACK TO GEORGE WASHINGTON.
IT WOULD MEAN ABOUT $65,000 PER
FAMILY IN AMERICA PER YEAR.
THAT IS WHERE THE DEMOCRATS ARE.
THEY ARE JUST -- DONALD TRUMP
HASN'T BROKEN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY, THEY HATE HIM
SO MUCH THEY ARE EMBRACING
POLICIES THAT WOULD DESTROY
POLICY AND OPEN UP OUR BORDERS.
IT'S WRONG.
>> Sean: OBAMA BIDEN EIGHT
YEARS, 30 MILLION NEW AMERICANS
ON FOOD STAMPS, A MILLION IN
POVERTY.
NOW 6 MILLION OFF OF FOOD STAMPS